foreign
guys let's talk to you before we get
into it about adamandeve.com all right
Adam and Eve is still offering amazing
prices at adamandeve.com get 50 off and
that's not it free shipping so it
actually equals out to be more than 50
if you're technical about it but 50
often Adventures new toy or slippery
Lube or almost anything else you desire
and uh our podcast listeners it's
specific to us okay uh we'll get 50 off
almost any item just use code Lifeline
at checkout and you get 50 off and
free shipping all right no matter what
you choose and it all sends discreetly
for free so you don't have to worry
about showing up in like you know the
packaging that might make you feel a
certain way uh so you go to
adamandeve.com select any one item use
the code lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e and this is an exclusive
offer specific to this podcast okay so
you're welcome and be sure to support
our show please and thank you and use
this code Lifeline to get you not just
the 50 off
no no no no but you also the 100 free
shipping code Lifeline go to
adamandeve.com right now right now
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
did it start are we recording
say yes or no yeah do that simply say
yes or no right okay cool great [ __ ]
yeah so it took so long to say yes what
was weird is that you asked I asked and
you asked again I said answer you said
it was like four or five prompts I mean
at least at least five right the clock
to start before but you didn't but it
doesn't matter does it to start the
clock and then say yes but what happened
is you didn't say that if you had said
that everything would have been clear
exactly even if you said actually guys I
just want to wait until the clock's on
it would have been way way better no I'm
trying to predict but exactly it starts
with an H you know exactly and dude I
will say this man uh welcome to Lifeline
welcome back to Lifeline everybody good
time with the uh Lifeline live that was
a [ __ ] gut win like gangbusters it
was very I think as of now that'll be
two episodes ago though right
oh yeah you're right two episodes ago I
do that now after I say something I go
there's nothing more insecure no because
it because I want to be cute when I say
something that might sound rude like oh
is that a size too small yeah it disarms
you honestly you just sound like an evil
villain no but what people get less
offended when you say something
offensive and then you sound very cute
at the end of that like oh that [ __ ]
hat looks bad on you I gave you herpes I
mean wow you know well that's not
offensive though
that is very offensive oh wow that'd
probably be the worst thing to ever say
to somebody especially if you did if it
wasn't a lie and you weren't and it was
true I got the lifeline sweater on the
crew neck let me tell you something
about those though very nice they look
so good on everybody that wears them
dude they're great I put mine on and I'm
[ __ ] I'm inches taller dude I just
grow that makes me cry but I grow uh
yeah so you can go to watch Lifeline to
get the uh watchlifefound.com to get the
merch uh and let people know call the
hotline uh I'll be in Denver when does
this one come out yeah Denver I'll be in
Denver uh and Boston coming up next uh
she'll go to chrysalia.com to get your
tickets to Denver and Boston
um and New York uh I got uh we sold one
show out at the Beacon and we added
another show at the Beacon hey New York
right yeah we're going to New York
February 18th and then that week later
we're going to Chicago not to mention
we're doing Lakeland Florida nothing
there's no more New York than getting
being in [ __ ] Florida right
especially during the cold months say
[ __ ] yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] forget about
it Jacksonville all that [ __ ] huh all
right so uh yeah Albany is sold out uh
and oh and Cheyenne dude Cheyenne first
time I've ever been in Cheyenne uh oh
what's that I'm hunting when I go to
Cheyenne everybody does this and
Cheyenne because they're always hunting
that's the most [ __ ] hunting of all
time like this no it's like this
okay dear now I'm hunting
I mean the worst play the worst play so
um Deer Hunter d-e-a-r um yeah dude okay
if you have a question go to the
description below or click uh or go to
watch lifeline.com okay so look man
so now why okay am I sweating so much
because I don't know because honestly
I'm not sweating that much so it I
probably have a thyroid problem is the
answer it all has to do with what I
don't know because sometimes you're you
know what I mean like it could be the
same temperature one day you're good one
day the next day same temperature and
you're sweating the most the most
fluctuation of body heat body
temperature is me that's poetry the
wrongest way to say that but you know
what I meant yeah
um no I don't actually know what you
meant so my body temperature fluctuates
more than anyone in the universe that
doesn't have a thyroid problem do you
have a thyroid problem I don't know so
you might I might but I don't know if I
do so I can't say that I do so I don't
have one okay so that's uh well I'm
sorry you know and if it gets hot we can
take a break we've done that before
you're sweating you're perspiring If I
Stay still I sweat less yeah that's par
for the course um don't make me move so
my neck hurts there I said it yeah
you're moving like Batman you're doing
this yeah I I know it really hurts and
it didn't hurt when I woke up which is
crazy usually when your neck hurts it
hurts from when you wake up right or you
pull it you know what happened dude do
you know what happened I have a guess
but go ahead okay go ahead guess
probably nothing absolutely nothing yeah
I'm sitting there holding Calvin we're
having a great time I'm sitting I'm not
even standing I'm not moving well you
were holding cow and you were exerting
summons no no oh okay he was literally
laying on me oh like this oh laying down
and all of a sudden my neck just decides
to go like this
and I'm in extreme pain so now what was
an explosion the pain
oh it was the pain rate that's the pain
rate in here
and does it go like this
no look at throbs or just it's one
extended pain nope it goes
and then congeals and it stays there and
it's always there the pain congeals so
that's great so now I pick poetry so now
I have pain radiates the pain congeals
worst doctor so now when I when I move
my neck it hurts very badly and I'm so
excited about that dude that's so
[ __ ] awesome has that been an ongoing
thing with you that area of your neck
nope never so now that I'm 42 that just
may be something that hurts all this
probably but my my back got better my
back it was my neck my back my my [ __ ]
and my crack and then my neck got better
uh I'm sorry my back got better though
what happened with your [ __ ]
we closed up yeah it got really dry
disgusting
um so anyway let's but but my point is
my back got better I [ __ ] had to go
and get a procedure and they give me
cortisone in my back dude you didn't
know that let's talk about cortisone
let's talk about how there's more
salesman let's talk about how there's
literally nothing better than a shot of
quarters is that really did it really
work that well I one time had my throat
was it was when I was really sick oh
yeah my throat was closing closing
closing and it hurt so bad to swallow it
probably hurt more than when women have
a baby come out of their vagina no wow
did the doctor say that the Arizona by
the way now now yeah it might be the fan
in the bathroom oh the fan right
I don't like that I gotta be honest it
makes me feel very uncomfortable when
you do that it might honestly might be
the fan of the bathroom okay
and so it could be this fan right here
yeah okay cool my throat was closing
right he said take off your pants and
bend over and you got a cortisone shot
you got this nurse got a cortisone shot
he didn't do it okay his female nurse
did and she injected it into my ass
cheek
and I felt so terrible when I was going
to the doctor yeah by the time I was at
the elevator to go down with four
flights from the doctor's office yeah I
felt so good I was like I'm gonna take
the [ __ ] stairs and I ran down the
stairs and I was like
all I wanna do is
Boom Boom
Matt yo I don't want you to be doing a
melody
would you call it a mix of songs medley
medley medley medley that's what I was
trying to say but I'm the king of the
medley and everybody that's fine but my
question is they gave you a cortisone
shot in your butt for your mouth dude
yes went to the wrong doctor no it
wasn't it wasn't obviously it wasn't
local but it just I went to where it
needs to go some drugs go to where it
needs but then how come they gave me a
cortisone shot in in where it hurts in
my back probably because
here's what I'm going to say oh and it's
and it's probably it's probably true oh
has no idea because it's different
[Music]
the thing I guess obviously a doctor
knows what he's doing he's like dude
they put me like take off your pants and
bend over just because he he's a that's
a he's not a priest you know what I'm
saying they bet they they put me on a
Gurney I guess face down injected me
with numbing [ __ ] and then injected my
my uh back with cortisone I mean that's
almost like how big was the needle big I
was like I'm not looking it's like a
spinal tap no it wasn't that I know but
it's like why would they do it like that
uh I don't know but my back felt [ __ ]
fantastic for one day
and then but they said this could last
for a year or one day literally oh dude
and I was like okay cool of course
lasted for one day and then and then it
got better over time and I don't think
it was the cortisone I think it was just
my body healing steroids are a crap
shoot they're steroids so that's why you
can't get a lot of them right exactly
because they'll leave a dimple in your
[ __ ] too that's what they said they said
that's why they did it in my butt though
they were like because it might leave a
dimple we don't want to do it anywhere
locally because then you'll look like
the [ __ ] uh uh the Joker or some [ __ ]
yeah I wanted to or they should do it on
the tip of my nose maybe make it a
little smaller well then you just be
like a butt nose I could afford to lose
some for my cup you know what I mean
that's why I said I was like oh well my
[ __ ] is so giant do you want to put it
onto that and then I took my [ __ ] out
and I was like see do you see what I'm
talking about the doctors are
no then I got sick now I got sued okay
cool
um yeah so my neck [ __ ] hurts so bad
and that's great and what what maladies
do you have uh I'm too sweaty right now
yeah
um my uh sleep's been extremely [ __ ]
up oh really oh yeah mine's been and
I've been having a very [ __ ] up
nightmares that are crazy Big Adventures
where I go to try to save someone and
instead of saving them I act I actually
in fact lead directly to their death
that is just you know so it's all good
that's fantastic yeah it's just
beautiful man it's gorgeous I have the
worst dreams when I go to sleep and then
wake up at 8 30 p.m and then sleep more
if I from wake up sorry 8 30 a.m okay if
I sleep in the morning my body goes like
this will terrorize you yeah yeah it
will terrorize it but you mean if you go
back to sleep did you want to see what
your dad would look like with no eyes
I'll close up here we go but you're
saying when you go back okay it's
because when you sleep for shorter
periods of time the dream you know it
doesn't get to go deep enough into your
mind for you to like it's too close to
your memory is what I'm saying when you
sleep for a short period of time because
you don't go to a deep enough sleep it's
like more of an actual memory and you
can remember it way better when you wake
up oh I know oh wow the only time
anybody's ever said that oh and then I
know
dude uh well you know what dude we
should get into it man you know we've
gotta we've got a lot of really great
callers probably and uh backtracked
let's see what's up dude let's go to our
first time
it's Hannah here you guys helped me with
the co-worker who had horrible stories
oh I have another advice is request for
you currently in Teachers College I'm
going to be teaching high school
students science
and people have been starting to tell me
that I should be worried about how the
boys in my classes are going to flirt
with me which I did not think about
until people started it seems to be the
only thing that people are mentioning
every time oh I'm not going to be
teaching high school students they say
that the boys are going to flirt with me
so now I'm starting to panic because I
have no idea what I'm gonna do
um so do you guys have any advice for
how I can kind of deflect and spin move
away when or if
my students try to hit on me hopefully
as a joke but nonetheless you she's
saying that here's the thing she's
saying that though people are telling
her that because she's pretty they're
being pervy they're like you know
they're gonna get hit on if she was some
frumpy fat chick nobody would [ __ ]
say that sure relax what about the
[ __ ] why is that why you said frumpy
fat chick why she's not that it hurt my
feelings is why she's not that she's not
but people are and some people heard
that and they're like ah [ __ ] I'm not
calling anyone frumpy or fat I'm look
fat is a word that means that if we went
over it then some people are that we
actually have an episode titled fat
frumpy two okay well that is the rude
part
because it implies but there are people
who are frumpy and fat yeah okay anyway
let's move on and her question isn't
about that either so her question is
what do I do if this happens and I'll
tell you the person you're just saying
I'm hot oh no okay I'll tell you what
you do and it's a little slightly
counterintuitive but I'll explain why
you'd have to do it this way okay there
obviously you want to put an end to it
yes but you cannot say something in
response that will make it that will
make other students laugh yeah or will
make the student who said it
think he's like being a Class Clown and
getting attention for it because that'll
only nothing will make him do it more
other than you just like turning around
and sucking his dick you know I mean
like if it the only thing
the only thing that would make him do it
more is if like
it it worked is what I'm saying yeah
which obviously won't work so short of
that the only thing that you could do to
make it more to embolden students to do
it more is if like you said something
that either was funny in itself even as
like a clap back you don't want to
engage with it at all don't do a clap
back yeah just just either completely
ignore it or say I'm going to report you
to the principal and then actually do it
okay don't egg it on in any [ __ ] way
don't clap back even though it's
obviously going to be tempting
especially if it's a [ __ ] offensive
thing to say yep don't don't slide into
that though like please don't you'll do
yourself a favor by just meeting it
head-on [ __ ] Doctor Strange style
stop it yeah that's what Doctor Strange
what if she did do that just stop it
that's what doctor strange I know he
goes he goes like this he goes stop it
trying to do the circle right the portal
um I think that honestly you you if you
did that and you went and she went to
the [ __ ] principal and the principal
was like he what if I mean he might be
like well it's probably because you're
not a frumpy fat chick well then then
she would sue that guy and get rich why
him because he's saying you are not a
frumpy fan because he's sexualizing her
and defending the students saying you're
not if the principal said well it's
because you're not a frumpy fat chick he
would be sexualizing her or contributing
to that and you should get [ __ ] fired
that's because you're not a frumpy what
is this I'm blowing his glasses oh wow
like a principle
um yeah no I know I'm kidding uh
honestly I think maybe uh just ignore it
completely and be like hey
um
just you know all right cool yeah let's
get the homework done you know or
whatever the [ __ ] but look at this 181
teachers charged with sex crimes during
first half of 2022. this is why you
can't say anything in return either it's
another reason you only either say
nothing and report it or say I'm gonna
report it and then report it you don't
clap back you don't say something smarmy
in return about the student's appearance
or his youth nothing okay you [ __ ]
the line is so [ __ ] thin now
everybody freaks the [ __ ] out about
everything especially in classrooms
don't slide that slippery slope you'll
go
worst Ted talk so I feel yeah no I feel
like yeah just that's it but also
sometimes they're [ __ ] kind of the
billboard is that Matt Dylan I mean
nobody
it could be no it's not oh my God [ __ ]
yeah I made up for the Leo DiCaprio ones
from Wild Things yep
um all right so I think uh I think that
also what was different about her she
did have a different hair color or
something if I remember correct she
looked like a different person to me wow
she didn't look Grumpy in fact well she
had her hair up and had glasses on I
don't think she did the first time all
right well let's do uh the next one okay
but yeah we figured that out for sure
take it off pause it I don't like when
hair peeks out of the Hat that's why
it's fine but if it's like that like
like an actual garden growing under his
hat take it out it's like it never it
looks like Chia Pet like he just [ __ ]
puts the hat on and then smears that
[ __ ] stuff and then Waters it and
then and then the Hat stays there and it
grows out a little bit like this is the
time lapse like that right but he's
trying to also hide his Chia Pet because
it's poking out from underneath right
also pubes pubes for sure 100 cubes on
his head yeah like there should be a
dick on his forehead yeah and there is
and that's why he's wearing a hockey
he's hiding it 100 all right cool and so
he figures out so let's do that
right now what I don't like is that
we've told Chris to make it so we can
pause it and it doesn't start over now
didn't we we did and what does it not do
when we talked about it when did we say
that we said that a while ago I did okay
so you could go from there yeah let's
see uh big fans of you both actually
um have been for a long time Matt
obviously got to you a little late in
the game Chris been a long time fan of
you for a long [ __ ] time through
thick and thin baby
so I need some advice
so my name is River and that's pretty
different nickname at least around here
you know like I'm thankful for it my
whole life I'm 24. I have dealt with
you know like the jokes on my name so
um which is cool like I don't care
because we're all kindergarten you know
um of course words that they use like
you know Lake ocean all that good [ __ ]
um so I messed with this girl on a
dating app the other night I know stupid
shouldn't be on that
um and she said nice to meet you Pond
and I go oh nice
pretty big talk from somebody with a
normal name what's your name with Shelby
good millions of them and so she uh then
she responded back with wow are you
victim blaming it's not my fault that my
parents name me that and I said no it's
not victim blaming if I'm saying it in a
way of I I know it's not your fault but
you have a normal last name so know your
normal last name place in life you know
so okay I'm not asking on I'm not asking
advice on how to deal with that I just
want funnier ways to respond back to
people that give me those kindergarten
uh nicknames like you know just the ones
that are just so on the nose and easy to
grab for it's a good question but uh
yeah thanks guys dude I think you should
say first of all I think he dealt with
it really well he did but he should say
actually that's funny because I wish we
were near a body of water so I could
drown you right now you know and kill
you in a river or anywhere or if they
say hi Pond you say interesting I wish
we were near a pond it's funny you bring
that up because I would love to drown
you
yeah for so long yes
yeah and then well now it's on social
media what you what you but yeah oh
right actually what you're saying no but
what you should do is honestly
right
all of the things that people say all
the time on cards okay and always have
them with you good and then you show
them and then when they when they say
one just go like this
yep yep yep
pick it out and go like this
it says do you know how many times
someone has called me Pond they would
feel
that would be good so molded dude yeah
yeah it's that would be so cold-busted
man yeah it's true that would be so
moted but also when you start like start
with a number that's already high don't
start at one because then when you pull
it out like don't start from scratch
when you make that list because then
when somebody does it and you're like
you know how many times people have
called me Pond and then they read it and
then it says like two no no no but just
no but just say something that people
often say to me is oh so there's no
counter I'll hand it to it right okay
yeah it would be so molded yeah what is
moded combusted oh call busted okay one
time when um
um one time when I was in second grade
uh
Mrs Beatty I I remember her yeah I had
her she was a frumpy fat one nope oh
then I don't know her don't okay so now
that was Miss banaxis okay but no but so
now you're being worse than I was in the
beginning I was just like calling it
back okay but that's fine but maybe
they're dead now who's Mrs Beatty Mrs
Beatty Beatty this is [ __ ] Mrs Beatty
was great he [ __ ] beat me off you
know what I'm saying no nope absolutely
not man okay okay okay
wonderful woman oh okay second grade
teacher and I was yeah I didn't have her
I had Miss Caldwell
I remember her match venon had her she
was pretty oh maybe it's not she
probably got hit on
she was really old right Mrs Caldwell
now she was very young oh damn I I don't
know okay so anyway um
Rasheed I remember Rasheed he was pretty
funny yeah yeah he was [ __ ] funny I
wonder what he's doing now
um he was saying something to miss beat
him Miss Beatty was like Rasheed no hold
on a second and hold on a second and and
Rasheed said oh that's called busted and
then miss Beatty said Rasheed if you
don't get out of my face I'm gonna go
bust it all over you whoa yeah dude and
it was so hilarious dude I laughed so
hard as you could imagine I mean even in
second grade he knew it was funny oh me
yeah I had never heard kobasa before in
my life oh so I was laughing I was
having a conniption thing I mean man it
was so funny uh that's called busted
if you don't get it in my face I'm gonna
go bust it all over the place so she was
I'm gonna go bust it so that would be a
version of clapping back not the best
idea in 2015 right exactly because she
because Rasheed could have went right to
the and she said the teacher said but
she was gonna bust on my face then she's
gone forever Witnesses I was a witness
so I would have been like she didn't
actually say that okay well the
principle but she did say that she
didn't know all over the place called
busted all over the place get caught
doing something you shouldn't while
you're convicted guilty of
um cold
it yeah they used it differently though
back then kobusted meant like [ __ ] up
not that wait wait hold it deliver
insulted that's what it was delivered
insult attempt to highlight inadequacy
I'm trying to raise money for college
your mom goes to God busted that's what
it was yeah right okay yeah hell yeah
dude wow Rasheed shout out to Rasheed I
wish I remembered Rasheed what the [ __ ]
was his last name I don't know
um Omar and Thomas
Omar pigs or Omar Holt Holt he had a
younger sister named Tatiana you
remember Tatiana she was a migrate yeah
yeah they looked exactly alike they were
both extremely beautiful and they both
looked exactly like somehow I gotta hit
up one more soon you're still friends
with him right yeah I would talk to him
in a bit but anyway you know we're just
having a conversation now but uh let's
go to the next one guys let's see what's
up
hey Chris and Matt love the podcast
Chris you're one of the funniest guys
around you make me laugh more than
anybody else they're just awesome been a
fan for Years anyway
uh I have a problem with uh my group of
friends right now uh I have I have one
friend who's not really a part of my
main group of friends and my main group
of friends does not like this person at
all wow um it's like four different
people they all think they're wild
boisterous to in your face just doesn't
fit the vibe I guess of what it usually
is when we all hang out the one guy but
I really like this person uh I've known
them for a long time I think they're fun
I don't get annoyed by the things they
get annoyed at and I just I'm just
wondering what should I do like if I
ever have like a football party at my
house or something like that I don't
want to not invite this person but I
also want all of my main friends to come
anyway yeah what should I do would they
not come see my whole thing is you don't
have to invite everybody to everything I
hate I don't like that like when people
are like what the [ __ ] you didn't invite
me I totally agree it's okay to not want
to we've we've we've talked about this
we've talked about this before I totally
agree but here's the thing this party's
at your house
exactly yeah you invite whoever the
[ __ ] you want to come to your
[ __ ] house no you know what I'm
saying that is the stupidest [ __ ]
thing
okay I kind of secretly like it but I
know you're doing it I know you do I
know you do look um I think that uh
honestly you gotta be this is my advice
to you dude you're you're legitimately
you can tell right away you're too nice
of a guy yep you gotta be more of a boss
in this situation if I who you want you
got to be like yo this is my friend he's
good I want you to feel me and feel why
he's good because you don't get it
you're out of the loop and aren't you
insecure about that that's the vibe he
has to have you're completely yelling
yeah okay Chuck's coming okay whether
you like it or not that's even more
intense the [ __ ] it's even more
[ __ ] if you can't see it I can't help
you but I'm the [ __ ] boss wow
now come to my Chargers party or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah come to come come
see the Baltimore Ravens Chuck's coming
and you bring the dip okay yeah you
could do that and then confrontational
and then yeah exactly but there's a way
to beat it and then you and Chuck scoop
that before he even hits the table when
they bring the dip scoop it eat it feed
Chuck here wow eat it Chuck and Chuckles
and then you both
ship and you both give it to the guys
such a disgusting party
like well that's nobody's gonna go if
that's the deal you know okay Chuck
Chuck feed him Chuck feed him now
whisper right everyone's just like uh we
don't nobody wants to yeah no look on
his face and [ __ ] dip okay so don't do
any of that stuff I I don't I disagree
it's your party invite whoever you want
if somebody has a problem with it that
is only their problem if he's if he's
your friend and you want to invite him
too ultimately you invite him too
especially if it especially if make the
potential to make that other friend feel
bad is higher and that affecting you is
higher than the price you pay for
inviting him and having your other
friends deal with it I I feel like
what's the higher cost you know yeah I
feel like it's basically just
you have to
um
that's a last kind of if if it all comes
down to it yes but I think that the
chips and the dip thing and then the
inviting Chuck and then being more of a
boss is the way to go okay I just think
the chips thing is a two confrontation
sure I understand but you know what I
mean you got to have that attitude of
like I'll feed you dip [ __ ] so
have the spirit of feed you have to feed
each other making Chuck feed him dead
but not literally do that you could I
would like that yeah Vibe of forcing
someone to feed chips to the other guy
yeah but you don't do it yeah but you
could do it you could do it but I don't
think he should I would do it but I
agree that this guy probably shouldn't
because he'd [ __ ] it all up in the
spirit of that is good but I don't think
you should literally do that yeah uh
invite who you want you could also
invite more people
and then this way they you know if
you're in your water inviting yeah yeah
exactly if you're just inviting four
Dudes and then also Chuck a guy they
hate yeah it's like oh I don't want to
go but this sucks man I've dealt with it
before if people don't like your friend
but uh
you've dealt with that a lot because you
have some of the worst [ __ ] friends I
invite them all anyway and they show up
because I [ __ ] have that feeding the
dip mentality and that's why I never
hang out with you well it's not why that
is one of the reasons why because you
always have at least three people who I
think Hmm Yeah you probably have like a
body in on in your that's so hilarious
dude that's you got a twisted sense of
humor but it's so funny because dude
it's like man they're so weird I love
weirdos I get that in a one-on-one sense
but I can't have too many around me at
once oh dude it's awesome I don't want
to feel like I'm at a carnival you know
like the weird Avengers yeah yeah like
you're at a Carney show yeah yeah it's
great your neck hurts so bad huh
but it's great dude it's great to have
the um to the weirdo the weirdos I ran
into John last night oh the Italian dude
we talked about him before on
congratulations oh yeah yeah My Italian
Friend how he has the action movie
acting class no I haven't talked about
that that shit's wild dude he has green
screen acting too dude he's a green
screen action star man I mean he's an
actor and he lives in Switzerland and he
teaches
action movies acting yes which is
hilarious yeah he's great I love him
he's awesome
very good guys living in Switzerland
really helps dude but yeah you're so
chill back in the day they used to send
people to Switzerland as like a health
uh to recuperate really yep I figured
that out on my own no you did not I
figured that out on my own that it's
good because I saw him after a few years
of being in Switzerland and he looks
great and he looks younger so I figured
out that Switzerland is a good place to
go and make yourself feel [ __ ]
carefree and fancy but thousands and
thousands of people figured out before
you that's all okay but I you needed to
learn it I already knew it because I
learned it you read it probably right I
acquired the knowledge fast
documentarian vast knowledge of many
many many things but I lived it it's
like that whole thing about it didn't go
to Switzerland right but I lived my
friend looking younger it's like that
whole thing where like they're sitting
down we're sitting down on the bench and
go to the hunting and you're Matt Damon
and you're like yeah I know everything
but I'm like but have you been to the
existing Chapel right right what it
feels like when you [ __ ] look at them
touching their fingers like that over
the monologue goes that's what I was so
I'm the smart one I hate that monologue
thank you yeah okay well it's I
understand you hate the monologue in
itself is good in the movie it kind of
explains everything and in the movie it
makes a movie not as good but the
monologue is good everything in the
movie is less good because it's in the
movie yeah I mean I basically agree yes
but the movie's good
uh I haven't seen it in way too long I I
just thought I have a feeling it is like
up to no Goods like some movies are so
manipulative I consider them up to no
good and Beyond The Tipping Point and
the weirdest critic we're just not good
and we give it two up to no Goods yeah
that's actually what I would do for sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right cool what
else movie is up to no good Vanilla Sky
okay next let's go uh yeah I mean
Vanilla Sky is up to Man Without a Face
cool let's go it's a niche Niche naughty
movie yeah okay everybody we are gonna
take a break and we're gonna take a
break to talk about diet smoke if you
love THC like I love THC then you will
love diet smoke all of diet smokes
products are guaranteed to give you the
beautiful Buzz you've been looking for
no prescription required no awkward
conversations no sketchy weed deals you
don't even need to go to a store
which is right you do but you don't even
need to do that for this you just decide
you want THC and then they ship it right
to your door bada bing bada boom all of
diet smokes products are made from
American grown hemp American made
meaning they're all federally legal and
each product has a lab test result for
potency and safety and guess what you
also have the mantelia test because I've
tried all these insane products and do I
love them yes I do love them diet smoke
just released several new flavors and
strengths like blackberry and apple
cider that you've got to try I've never
heard never or tasted Edibles this good
also check out the merch got the hat on
one last thing they're guaranteed 100
satisfaction or your money is actually
refunded you can literally can't miss
with diet smoke so if you're ready for
the perfect high like I have been uh
head over to diet smoke.com and use the
code Lifeline for 20 off your entire
order you must be 21 or older to order
but you know what it's worth it let's do
it back to the show baby
all right next one holy [ __ ] Matt you
read it what's good Chris and M diesel I
won't keep you guys waiting so here you
go kept us waiting just waiting just get
into it I'm a 21 year old dude who's
still a virgin and never had a
girlfriend there's a 25 year old
absolute MILF she's a best friend of
quote or parentheses bear with me now my
brother-in-law's brothers be baby baby
mama Jesus who started out by following
me on Instagram and liking my stories
and then adding me on Facebook and
Snapchat we've been talking I mean has
Tourette's we've been talking over snap
the last week or so but the thing is
that her ex who's the father of her two
kids is an absolute lunatic from the
stories I've heard should I
should I keep talking to her and see
where it goes or keep stepping instead
of wasting my time like I have every
other time I love you all thank you
Chris for making for Loki saving my life
and thank you Matt for being Chris's
much more logical but just as funny and
much sexier brother so political he
didn't say that part okay sexier and
cooler and [ __ ] just astonishingly
great brother and his Instagram here is
Justin or dealy or o-r-d-i-l-l-e
um yes it is okay uh there's a picture
of him look how cool that's a picture of
him he's a great diesel as [ __ ] huh yeah
he's a good guy I mean where the
pictures taken is hilarious what a great
guy yo let's go do that Lifeline picture
under the [ __ ] it's like his head
shot or something his graffiti artist
headshot so uh absolutely don't stop
talking to this girl just because her ex
is up according to many a lunatic like
well you don't know like just go get it
dude like you can't back down from a guy
who you literally never even met just
heard stories about come on dude he has
no experience with him
she does not know the guy and also he's
never had sex dude go and don't stop get
it get it
this is all sorts of [ __ ] up okay
there's so many [ __ ] [ __ ] ups here
wow okay go I mean this guy he's never
had sex he's gonna have sex with a
[ __ ] whatever that's not a [ __ ] up
he's only 21. no no no no that's not a
[ __ ] up but I'm saying this for the
first time it's all starts to [ __ ] up
dude all right I mean it's too much
going on dude first of all explain okay
he's he okay so he's never had a
girlfriend whatever he's ever whatever
uh there's a 25 year old she's older
which is okay uh brother-in-law's
brother's baby mama read just too much
right brother-in-laws okay okay okay
okay so brother-in-law's brother's baby
mama so already has a baby with somebody
that he knows right yeah yeah two babies
that [ __ ] two kids
really yeah my brother-in-law's baby
mama okay all right so whatever that
doesn't matter one or two it doesn't
even matter but who started out by
following me on Instagram and liking my
stories she
that's a bit of a [ __ ] like that's
nothing naughty movie but I don't like
how people are like oh my God
I agree but the whole thing is if she's
got it going on and she starts doing
this she needs to know what the weight
she pulls with in the gotta going on
territory is okay right can you explain
that my point is if you're bad as [ __ ]
and you're a baby Mama's person that
knows this [ __ ] 20 year old dude's
virgin guy and you know you got it going
on right yeah then you're gonna follow a
guy and you know it's like it's like
when a hot chick is like man I really
wish I could
help you know with my taxes and some
guy's like I I could probably do it you
know what you're doing you're giving
that guy false hopes to squirting no
dude that that that that that that that
that that's too close to a bad argument
dude I don't I don't that's not right
it's a great argument it's not what if
she [ __ ] needs some other [ __ ]
taxes is yeah I know that you go to
somebody who does that [ __ ] not just
some guy who's [ __ ] hoping to get
squirt to squirt but come on dad what's
wrong with that why would she not ask a
guy who wants to help her to help her
just because she thinks he might want to
get to squirt because she'll get it for
free
basically there's different levels of
hooking is my point oh no don't no no
there's not We're not gonna go down that
Avenue look it's fine but I'm saying
be it if you're gonna be it you're
you're suggesting that this wouldn't be
a hooker no no no I'm saying it's a
skill she's on the mini end of it and
coupled with all these other red flags
it's a bad guy liking his photos no
coupled with all the other [ __ ] the baby
mama the the adding uh the uh uh uh ex's
father who has two kids absolute lunatic
oh from the stories of her doesn't know
it it's just a lot it's just a lot to
take in I think here's my advice okay
just I have sex with her yeah I'm not
saying definitely don't do it I'm just
saying you better be prepared if it
wasn't if he's had sex before he knows
how to deal with it but dude he's gonna
slide in and he's gonna fall in love
dude okay well beware buyer beware on
that don't fall in love that's a bad
idea that's what I'm saying it's a sign
maybe you like you roll out you have a
couple [ __ ] Halloween nights you have
a good time and you slide in and then
slide in uh-huh with this woman okay I
just think stop worrying you're 21 and a
virgin like are you kidding me like
you're so young you've never had sex go
live make a mistake or two who gives a
[ __ ] like yeah go just go do it who
cares that's true all right take take
more pictures under that overpass it
looks [ __ ] alien yeah he looks
[ __ ] dope that guy all right cool
sounds good next
hi Matt and Chris hi my question is do
you have people in your life who are
allowed to fart and people who aren't
what a great question uh my buddies were
over the other day and one of them
farted and I was appalled and disgusted
and said no don't do that wow and he was
rightfully offended because apparently a
few minutes earlier our other buddy
farted and I giggled
I had to dig deep inside myself and
question why can't you and why can he
and why
um
and I can't find any explanation other
than you're just not that guy like you
just can't and I proceeded to make a
list of people in my life who can and
the list of people I can't find any
similarities she's funny
um
what's that about am I just being a fart
gatekeeper does it make sense
think about the people in your lives who
can and can't have fart rooms here's
what I think
no one can fart around me yeah don't not
no and I can also fart around everyone
that's how everyone feels but it's like
it's like you're on spit like you can
look at your own spit when someone else
spits it's like you [ __ ] pig people
farting it is because it leaves a
[ __ ] Trace but it's like you know
somebody farts and it's like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] Pig like David
Sullivan farts so much you know I was
just with him yeah of course he did
because he's got that big [ __ ] head I
don't like that and he's [ __ ] gross
and he [ __ ] wears shorts and he farts
and [ __ ] can't smell it
so I can't eat cheese man and then he
does anyway where's Savannah yeah you
pay the price we were in Savannah we
were in Savannah and he was he was there
in Savannah and did his Film Festival
his film festival coincided with Mike oh
cool and he was there and he was like
yeah I'll get this without cheese though
oh wow and then the guy left and I was
like man you [ __ ] gotta eat cheese
and like nah it makes me fart man if I
eat that special around people I'll
start farting immediately man why does
he act like he cares he doesn't care
that guy's a [ __ ] disgusting fart
machine so dick he doesn't my point is
so dick he doesn't eat cheese a lot when
I was around me but I make him do it and
then I tell him not to fart because I
want him that's torturous but okay so
here's where you saw a movie
you've been bypassing eating cheese so
much and not farting but now you're
subjecting people around you to the
stench of your insides here's some
Parmesan eat it and fart your way out oh
I want to play a game
hahaha
[Music]
took so long to get to the joke you know
oh walks around if you're like oh okay
so the detectives later
I think I know what happens yeah is
Chris Rock for some reason
I don't know what happened Chris Rock
Okay so
I smell farts so Sam Jackson background
God damn farts no one
is allowed to fart around me I just
watched spiral okay
no one is allowed to fart around me no
one is allowed to burp her on me no one
is allowed to be [ __ ] disgusting
around me without my Express
permission Moses [ __ ] signed
contract saying it's okay I mean
permissions you know you need signed
permission to fart a [ __ ] just keep
it walk out of the [ __ ] room
walk out of the [ __ ] room you're
gonna fart I won't you won't but that's
great you don't it's gross your farts
smell like [ __ ] death that's not true
your farts smell like decomposed corpses
after 30 seconds after I put Altoids up
my butt okay well they [ __ ] don't
work okay
none of this is true guys I do know what
she means though about how some people
are less gross when they fart and some
people are more even if they're the same
fart but for me it's a no fart rule just
don't do it your house is in no fart
Zone unless it's you and I'm alone yeah
right right are you dude if I'm in a
room with somebody I don't [ __ ] fart
no the other way around you no because
you've got to be honest when I am in a
room and I fart I'm being me I'm giving
you all of me I'm not holding back no
one wants respectful that's not
respectful no one wants all of you they
go I go you're welcome that's yeah come
on you want me to not be me you're a
psychopath
you're straight up psychopath who was
the person that called in we're just
kind of started to talk about oh yeah I
think that there's a no farts on it
that's really I really like that you
have a list of people who can and can't
fart yeah and I think that you should
brief people on who can and can't yeah
yeah totally but like and then when they
say why not me you say honestly because
I think you're more disgusting than the
other guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're the kind of guy I don't want
to smell their insides yeah you're gross
you gross me out already yeah and then
when you fart it puts you over the
[ __ ] Edge because you're disgusting
you [ __ ] pig so dick so I think but
also some parts sound wet some people do
well come on I don't do I want my shit's
dry but I don't do wet ones but
sometimes you hear like their cheeks
you know and it's disgusting as [ __ ]
yeah it's so gross and then dude have
you ever farted but and then [ __ ] by
mistake not me I never honestly I
actually never have done that I've heard
people talk about me too Eric Griffin
talked about it last night oh well then
now that is gross yep he farted dude and
he didn't know any any [ __ ] when he took
a Steppy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then like get up and be like oh I
bet when he tells the story he describes
the farts 100 yeah yeah yeah because
that's his signature move all right
first time I met him I was astonished at
how many times he did this I know yeah I
know it's disgusting one-on-one yeah I
was farting [ __ ] coming everything
was that dude with privates everything
everything is squirting okay cool next
yo Chris saying what up from Scotland
right now
um I'm attending University here and
life rips uh until recently when a
situation involving my best friend and
our conflicting love life and a little
bit of backstabbing has been making me
blood red mad oh no
um anger isn't something I really feel
ever
um so it feels kind of foreign but it
feels kind of good in that it's like
pushing me to want to do better in all
aspects of My Life
um
so because it's kind of out of spite I
could see how that could be unhealthy
but maybe it's uh maybe it's for the
better
um so yeah I'm just wondering if you
guys think anger can be a good thing if
it's experienced occasionally and
handled in a way that is productive or
if you should avoid it entirely and how
do you guys deal with anger uh yeah
appreciate the advice guys peace
you can't avoid it entirely so you have
to embrace it yeah it's like it's not
something you don't agree they're gonna
die when you're 48 yes exactly because
somebody's going to cut them off of the
car he's gonna be like this huh
like literally you felt no the detectors
are gonna be like no nothing happened
you just felt no anger and then all of a
sudden some cut him off and it was too
much and it's easier
what the heck what's going on
you can't hold in all anger because the
truth is if you're not if you never
express anger you're a [ __ ] liar and
you're scary because everyone feels
Anger from time to time it's just
another version of sadness uh and it's
sadness that bothers us so much we don't
we can't control it we can't deal with
it so we start [ __ ] getting furious
right that's why my men get more mad
than women because they don't like to
deal with sadness and what are you doing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so close
[Music]
the war shot going from the [ __ ] eye
to the mouth you know so bad
dude
um you have to be mad are you really not
mad or are you just convincing yourself
your mouth he said he's blood red mad he
said he is okay so then what's he saying
he's talking about
letting that out and of course you have
to let that out yeah go try boxing or
something talking to your [ __ ] friend
about it man oh yeah like and let it let
yourself be angry don't be mean there's
see here's the thing yeah there's a
difference between being angry and mean
yeah so you're allowed to express anger
but you're not allowed to be mean it's
like it's like the difference between
you can't feel bad for things that you
feel but you can feel bad for things
that you do yeah based on those feelings
you can be you can be like God damn it
I'm so pissed off at you but you can't
be like I'm so pissed off at you and
you're short yeah yeah that would be
yeah that would be uh and you're frumpy
and fat Okay I I think uh yeah what's
weird about this guy is he's very
articulate and speaking about it like he
kind of knows what's happening which is
the opposite of people who don't want to
deal with their emotions so I'm going to
go ahead and say he's a sociopath we've
diagnosed him
I mean no I think he just bottles it up
too much and yeah no he would be a
sociopath if he like didn't
feel those things yeah okay I guess so
you're right right yeah so what you want
to do is
let it out like even if it's into a
pillow just hold it over your face and
go ah
wow
good gonna let it out
I'm gonna let it in
from counterintuitive they hit
counter-intuitive um all right so I yeah
I think that that's probably you gotta
you gotta talk to your friend yeah dude
yeah
it's bad news get to it you're gonna get
cancer and you're gonna die at 40. yeah
you will get cancer dude someone's not
going to say excuse me you're going to
be like
you can't bottle it up that much yeah do
a wet fart and die
hey Chris hey Matt this is beautiful in
Texas
so I have some
put your opinion on or need some advice
on
um it's a subject that is a little
slightly embarrassing just because it is
being broadcast of the world but you
know
so
for as long as I can remember
right when I hit the
hit
um it's it's you know yeah before I
clean myself with soap that's cool
um I want to be all over myself I just
pee
watch everybody get
up with my husband
gross disgusting oh come on
um he doesn't understand
well why don't you just
the warm water makes you want to pee
there well I mean that's fine but
I it's like saving a couple minutes okay
so that's one
I just wanted to see the president you
guys be in the shower does Kristen be in
the shower is it a normal thing or am I
really that disgusting so I just wanted
to know if Kristin but
set the whole thing up just so no I
don't know so here's the thing your
husband's a [ __ ] weirdo people that
are like oh you pee in the shower and
then I get in there like show us the
most sanitary [ __ ] place in the
world because soap is constantly running
across the floor of the [ __ ] shower
People are cleaning themselves in the
shower yes they're getting the dirt off
their bodies but guess where the dirt
goes down the [ __ ] drain nothing dude
that's not gross at all people it was so
stupid man it is not it is not gross I I
don't know it I don't know this guy just
has a weird thing about it I guess but
also like how many showers are you're
taking with your significant other I I
can't even think of like maybe I've done
it five times
you know like I that's how much is he
getting mad at this just pee or don't
take showers with him I don't think it's
even because he's with her oh he's just
[ __ ] oh what the [ __ ] that's what I'm
saying that's ridiculous then that's
ridiculous that's exactly what I'm
saying yeah right right exactly okay
that's everything you know yeah you
don't want to lie but also like what the
[ __ ] it's like if someone's being that
petty and stupid and it's that small of
a thing you can lie about it but also if
you want to be like sometimes you don't
need to pee before you go in the show
and you get in the shower and you're
like oh that warm water makes me want to
pee warm water makes you want to pee you
think that's what's going on with her
well yeah man when you you know the
whole thing is like put your hand in a
when you're sleeping all right right
right
I don't know I tried to do it to you
once you didn't piss you did that to me
yeah it didn't work why'd you do that to
me we were young how young
you were 35. no you were uh you know we
were in New Jersey oh no we were
knocking out that's a horseshit thing to
do man while I tried to do it man well
[ __ ] you dude well one time I also put a
[ __ ] a watch in your pillowcase
and it ticked so much and you were so
and you were so mad and you were like
Dad what is this ticking noise and he's
like I don't hear it Matt and I heard it
from the other room and I was laughing
so hard you are a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and you were like I hear it he's like no
it wasn't why is that funny you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's uh it was funny to me at the point
it's not funny [ __ ] you dude I went in
that's probably why I'm so [ __ ] up
dude you [ __ ] with me I took you I
took the watch out well you shouldn't
have put it in well it was
fun for a while and it's fine how long
was it in there a few weeks no no no
that night I took it out you got up and
I like sneakily was like what's going on
and I took it out bad brother
[ __ ] bad evil evil villain
[Laughter]
I'm the MacGyver of [ __ ] pranks I
mean not is that not even that crafty
you know the bowl with the warm and the
piss in yourself is the thing the the
watch and the thing is not a thing and
I'm you know who uh we did that too was
uh Mike manorelli at Wrightwood so
Italian and he did it
hey what's going on I'm Mike Myron
what's his name manorelli Mike Marinette
manorelli Mike marinara
hey what's going on my name is Mike
marinara you want to buy a [ __ ] car
come on down I'll also sell you some
other stuff depending on what you need
it's like that comedian Mike Moreno yeah
Mike Marino Jesus Christ he's funny one
time Mike America Italian again oops it
was never Italian one time one time
so stupid you know one time Mike Marino
was on stage before me and he was
[ __ ] absolutely crushing and I
couldn't I [ __ ] and I couldn't follow
him really yeah dude the crowd was older
but I mean the crowd was older and I was
like oh Jesus Christ okay okay Mike
Marino you win and he was just doing get
the bat yeah right right that's his
thing yes Italian thing ever so nobody
has bigger cuffs on their shirts that
they roll up like he goes like this and
he hits himself in the face they're so
big dude yeah this like this right yeah
how do you know about that you know his
[ __ ] I mean yeah I noticed [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] smart
um love Mike Moreno he's uh he is funny
that's true how are you doing [ __ ]
ridiculous
always you know shoulders just milk in
the [ __ ] tally [ __ ] make America's
hanging was never a time did you know I
was Italian
yes yeah pasta sauce in his [ __ ]
spaghetti out of his pants I think
Sebastian's a [ __ ] step away from
just having like meatballs falling out
oh he so does that time
[Laughter]
oh oh the guy that the De Niro
impersonator he does yeah oh I didn't
know that and he's not even that good
it's hilarious oh I gotta [ __ ] look
it up what I like Instagram and [ __ ]
yeah dude well yeah he hangs out with a
De Niro impersonator oh my God I mean of
course he does though you know that's
hilarious wow it is [ __ ] funny his
shit's funny yeah oh yeah yeah Mike
Marino live I think is his Instagram
handle which is great so which is great
old comedian to add live at the end ah I
don't know I do I do know okay so it's
okay that you don't know you don't need
to know I got you covered I do know and
it's true I don't think that that's true
I don't care what you think I would use
crystally alive I know I'm old for a
fact all right all right that it is true
fine fine fine thank you all right next
one
in a [ __ ] town of countries
wearing no pants balls in country
magazines
oh [ __ ] balls of country man
oh [ __ ] man
oh man this guy couldn't [ __ ] be like
the sixth seed tennis in his [ __ ] oh
dude every every every
color in this shot is a different shade
of the same color yeah on him on his
skin the back the brick the [ __ ] uh
couch his balls balls and Country
magazines wow dude Jesus this is this is
the cover of balls and countrymax yeah
all right cool next I mean not next
episode 29 of Lifeline right now or just
started it uh and you know I thought I'd
ask for a little bit of advice myself so
great nice um I'm the seventh grade
basketball coach
for a boys basketball team I'm good and
I started doing it last year
ton of fun I love coaching
um super fun age to coach to be around
but
you know I can only take 12 kids on the
team and this year there's going to be I
think like 19 or so trying out
seven
um so
it's my least favorite part of the year
every year every every season it's it's
besides wearing pants terrible not fun I
hate that um you know I think I dislike
it as much as the kids who get cut
dislike it uh it's not enjoyable in the
slightest and I was wondering if I could
get some advices about uh how to how to
break the news to the kids that are not
gonna make the team
um
I think that'd be pretty helpful uh so
I'd like to hear what you got thanks
that's got to be rough wow
them down one by one what else to show
his body he takes the phone back to his
bedroom and then cuts it and here's what
you do you don't start with how much of
a great person you are you start with
the fact that unfortunately he didn't
make the team but he didn't make the
team yeah but then you talk to him about
him about the kid across from you you
tell him how great he is what you do
like about him don't but don't here's
the key kids especially kids that age
are hypersensitive to when they're being
fed [ __ ] uh just make sure you pay a
lot of attention to these kids when
they're uh trying out for the team
especially the ones that you know you're
gonna cut and start filing away the
things you could tell them about
themselves that aren't [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the best you can do it sucks
either way that that would be terrible
that would be I would [ __ ] hate that
dude but they can smell [ __ ] kids do
it especially seventh eighth grade that
age they're ready for it their parents
lie to them all the time about how
[ __ ] great they probably are yeah
they used to parents say stuff like that
uh what what they say I'm not high and
they've been doing rails of cocaine okay
yeah there's that too probably
um
so deeper you know well I mean our
parents terrible childhood uh but no but
uh that's so that's what my but it will
be like look you didn't make the team
but you have nice hair next bring Phil
in here Phil uh no not that you know but
but the thing I said yeah that is what
you're saying you're dedicated a few
like actual minutes to it though don't
like don't let him like leave uh uh I'm
just thinking about it like kids
probably cry that sucks but definitely
do it one-on-one uh in a behind a closed
door whatever the [ __ ] yeah where other
kids can't hear well but you need to
have another adult in the room oh yeah I
guess so right yeah that's [ __ ]
stupid but go ahead yeah what about you
no I mean that's all I mean I agree like
it's [ __ ] it's tough that sucks my
heart goes out to you I have to do that
[ __ ] and ruin a kid's life because
that's what you're doing
you know what else he's doing though
he's exposing his balls to these kids
and that's not good either
I like guys who could Rock shorts like
that my legs are [ __ ] horrible how
about how good I am calling when
someone's athletic when someone's
[ __ ] this and that when it says I
said six British players wild yeah I'm
great yeah
uh this one wasn't that good though you
said tennis it was good you didn't say
coach it's like a number of things you
didn't get okay well all you did was
like say a sport and then he said a
sport
you know
honestly my necks hurt so bad when I did
that that I thought I was not gonna be
able to move past that not be able to
continue the podcast well we're almost
done here one more we'll do one more
yeah and then moan about your neck
oh what's going on Chris and Matt uh
love the podcast I will be seeing you
Chris at the Beacon Theater in New York
[ __ ] city.com and that leads me
to my question I am going alone did I
ask my friends to come yes did they want
to come with me
did I get VIP meet and greets to see you
after the show yes did I want to buy my
girlfriend another VIP meet and greet to
come with me absolutely not so I'm going
alone I've never done that before how do
you navigate those Waters at a comedy
show or a concert do you sit down in
your chair you look to your left look to
your right hey I'm here by myself want
to be friends how do you navigate it
would appreciate any help and I will see
you February something don't know the
exact date peace
dude that's hilarious I actually think
it's cool to go to anything alone dude I
love going to [ __ ] alone you know I mean
comedy is one of those things you want
to experience with somebody if they
really want to go to yeah and you're
like yeah you know but if that you're if
you're not gonna bring somebody like
that go alone go alone people always
comment on like my Instagram I see like
oh you should I go alone I'll be driving
from dude it's like such an awesome
experience by yourself because you don't
get interrupted you're just watching and
you get to take it in and you're also
with a bunch of people that are
like-minded because they all like the
same person I love it you're definitely
not the only [ __ ] there alone
first of all yeah second of all you're
right it is a little bit different in
comedy you want that person there where
you want to like [ __ ] you know like
elbow and be like yeah how funny is that
but also like movies and [ __ ] I oh I
mean I I wouldn't say I prefer to go
alone but it's just the same like you
want to sit and watch a show you're not
gonna be talking during the show yeah
the only thing is on the way there and
on the way back but [ __ ] that yeah if
you go alone to yeah you go to alone but
if I liked music I would go to music
shows alone because other but that's
probably why I don't like music but like
to go experience it by myself and I have
somebody being like talking while I'm
doing while I'm watching movies I would
go alone
um or you know a magic show this way you
can just really be like wow wow by
yourself you know what I mean is that
real by myself you should just go in a
magic show in any capacity is kind of
[ __ ] depressing
okay I'll show you what's the magic
shirts that are absolutely magic trick
I'll show you some of my magicians that
are absolutely amazing I mean I've seen
them I just don't have these ones Man
David [ __ ] Blaine yeah but there are
certain I've I've had I've eaten with
David Blaine okay that's just the lunch
house so it's so weird a Mad Lib
next to Al Pacino I was sitting such a
madlib and David Spade or David Spade
David what's his name I don't know David
uh you just said Sullivan no the [ __ ]
magician oh David Bland David Blaine was
doing card tricks to Al Pacino and
Albert she was like oh wow oh oh wow and
I was just eating pasta next to it and I
was like what is my life that is such a
such a Mad Lib holy [ __ ] and [ __ ]
wasn't Arnold there yeah I mean what the
[ __ ] what were you guys made the food oh
yeah what was happening I don't know
and I went uh
and I went and [ __ ] I was eating
pasta That Guy Fieri made and how good
was it it was good just regular really
good no it's really good oh I mean if
Guy Fieri didn't make it and I ate I'd
be like wow that's really good but
because it did make it you're kind of
not impressed no he did make it I was
like okay yeah this is great okay got it
it wasn't like
you know you didn't have to like it was
really good right okay it was really
good nothing to be home about go to his
restaurants oh okay yeah there's nothing
yeah 100 okay so what the [ __ ] was the
party what was the unboxing oh okay that
oh my God that makes sense okay and I
went and [ __ ] David Blaine was doing
you want a bigger car you want to pick a
card and I was like oh oh oh oh and I
didn't want to pick it and he did what'd
you get is this your card I was just
like oh it was and I was just like oh my
God the craziest party ever yeah it was
dude and dude and I was watching and Guy
Fieri was in the background like this
uh all right cool so that's what's up do
we give him advice I don't remember what
it was I don't remember either but we
did yeah it doesn't matter done with it
um I think we gave him uh what did he
want to know what was he talking about
magic oh we're gonna go in the show
alone yeah [ __ ] go alone own that
[ __ ] you're the best dude you're the
[ __ ] man hell yeah you're [ __ ] man
dude uh and I'll see you there dude and
I'll meet you at the meet and greet
that's great yeah dude go say what's up
to my brother I definitely won't be
there
you might be there I mean
all right cool uh if you want uh to uh
leave a uh have a question to send in a
video watch lifeline.com get the merch
here Lifeline uh merch.com and most
importantly if you want to want a
one-on-one advice session with me MD so
yours truly go to fuckingmadelia.com 1
30 to 5 30 Pacific time every Tuesday
and Thursday I make myself oops
available to you and go make an
appointment on magulia.com thank you
you should have done that afterwards and
also I'll be in Denver coming up go get
your tickets chrisley.com and I'll also
be in Boston and New York and Chicago
and Lakeland and [ __ ] all sorts of
different places in Jacksonville and
Portland and Seattle it's nuts Micro
Machines guys
[Music]